and hmm okay hello and welcome to this
video playing on comm and he plays a
Patrol yeah the bishop before I'm is
extremely solid but also a little bit
better for white black now has this
basic choice play with f3 play with d5
or 26 he decided to play with d5 okay so
what is my setup here
[Music]
hey I'd like to play f3 okay
membership III was probably not the most
precise 9f5 now for him it's but it's
annoying not what I wanted
okay no 95 hmm
that's what I expected to happen
hmm I have C for now and think I'm going
to play it the six is unprotected so
this move is possible it's not like b3
was without any idea my QP position
should be quite nice so I'm going to
take I wasn't sure about this what's
best here okay I'm fairly certain that I
have to play c3 in the foreseeable
future but first of all this one having
Bishop f6 and 95 in this position and I
would like to play a three that would be
really nice to get in without any
further concessions just to control the
four square
mmm yeah I'm Knight f5 and he still he
has this still on the agenda yeah that's
an interesting moment now I can take his
sex that's an interesting choice I
wonder if it is a good choice but Bishop
f3 is also interesting yeah why not him
activate the bishop don't play a 390 for
the receive for again again decide yeah
okay that I did not have on the radar on
I can win a pollen take here take d5 not
sure how good that is
but keeping the pressure on is also
probably quite ok click on to e5 as well
hmm ok
no big deal okay what is he thinking
about you isn't 9600 when you move
anyway oh that's something that I should
not have overlooked gents like looks
very normal I mean I think we need four
is quite a good reply but still it's not
I should have taken it into account okay
yeah that's the thing if you black is
giving Y to the two bishops really early
on and if you can open it up like that
blacks position is not good that's very
tough now
okay so we sacrifice a piece I guess I
can take even with the rook
don't know if that is better than
checking with the bishop
they're probably not a huge difference
or c3 now move that is problematic c3
like c3 Queen takes the 8c takes between
some nonsense like that maybe lassie 3 I
should probably take just with the
bishop okay and now I can take with the
rook c3 but it cannot be great
it's taking it somehow an option no I
don't think so
Bishop takes there so it's a threat no
no they are not there let's make sure
that I'm not getting back rank mated
see one is controlled quite reliably
even if okay one now
I get the bone it was important don't
have that many pawns left that is
something I've got three pawns left so
we have to be sure that night maid as
something that is maybe possible here it
with an increment I should it's it's
something that I can do
oh that was a bit stupid putting it to
g4 that doesn't make much sense the
knight should head to c5 I can also
bring the King to c5 it's also not bad
okay now g4 is an additional weakness
that I can probably win ah he do his own
time
I would I would like to show the further
technical phase but it's not difficult
now I think we should page find this is
I'm winning another pawn okay so maybe
there was a technical error here and
there but I was reasonably happy with
how this unfolded Bishop e3 is maybe not
the most precise move here that's
something that not I'm not really
certain
maybe rook e1 and then we should be
three it's it's not a big issue I mean
this is one of those lines that is going
to be eternally better for white anyway
9650 one v b3 I'm planning 44 at the
right moment and yeah 97 is stumbling
into it a little bit though the engine
wants to sacrifice the exchange that's
interesting
not going to be enough probably know
what's not enough yeah but okay and the
Queen and if he's able to take 94 but
I'm better
probably Bishop f3 is what I would have
played before seems to be strong but not
a move that I would have played probably
24 so make sense just carry three after
Knight f6 I should be a lot better take
stakes and the engine just wants to grab
the pawn
why not but this is a keeping complete
control Bishop f3 must be ok should be
yeah I've thought about this stamp it
should be 5 but this is fine and now I
went a 4 which is probably something you
can improve upon
but yeah it's given us one of the top
choices and she after Kuni flights if
that's a disaster already I went C form
I said a banner
no what would have been surprised that's
that's completely opening up the center
and the two bishops now are fantastic I
decided to give material of it
pair up cakes was less precise which is
just bishop takes is stronger and it's a
piece I mean it's a piece here yeah this
move that that was what I was thinking
and it was a little bit irritating I had
it I would have done that at the end but
it's not it's not super clear this is
the the line and I felt I must be ok but
those three pieces are really really
loose really loose
they I should take with the bishop and
it's such a strong one at the way it
turned out I think I'm just winning i
mean maybe i blundered somewhere it's
always possible that this position
should be a winner
yeah until you're just going to wind up
win the pawn and wouldn't the game I
probably didn't go for the most
straightforward conversion but I think
it was never in danger thanks a lot for
watching